hey guys it's justine and today i am so
excited because in front of me is the
latest and greatest in cat technology
this is the brand new litter robot 4 and
this is a self-cleaning cat litter box
now you're probably saying justine we
know that you do not have a cat so why
would you be unboxing this and showing
it to us well my friend ed has two cats
lincoln gus and i have basically watched
these cats grow up from the day that he
got them to now and i'm so excited
because he actually has one of the older
versions of this a huge thank you to
litter robot 4 for partnering with me on
this video i am so excited to unbox this
and take it over to my friend ed's house
and get his kitties a litter box upgrade
here we go
i just love finding really cool pet tech
because i feel like so many of us have
animals and anything that can make our
lives easier i'm a huge fan of oh i love
this it says best day ever for you and
your cats i also have a feeling knowing
ed's cats that they would probably
really love this box so this is the
white version there is actually two
colors i asked ed what color he wanted
and he chose the white so i'm very
excited to see what this looks like in
his place we've got the power adapter
here
here it
is i'm so excited for his cats to get
this
look at this
it's kind of awesome because you put the
kitty litter in and then when your cat
uses it and it goes to the bathroom it
then spins and rotates and gets the the
potty all clumpy and then you can just
empty it right here in the tray that is
so convenient
it does look like a little spaceship
well now that it's unboxed uh let's go
head to ed's house and see what his cats
think you ready jen yeah okay let's go
[Music]
i love that this has an app for your
phone that you can connect to and
monitor waste it's self-cleaning so
there'll be a clean bed of litter every
time your cat uses it it also has odor
control and a carbon filter to reduce
any unwanted smells this is suitable for
up to four cats so if you do have more
than one then this is great for sharing
i love that it has a safe cat system so
it makes sure your cat is safe when
using the litter robot it's super quiet
easy to clean and reduces airborne and
surface litter dust
and your surprise is here um it's
actually not a surprise because i told
him i was coming over and i told him
exactly what i was bringing i'm so
excited for you to check this out hi
link you're so scared oh my gosh don't
be scared it's it's a spaceship you have
the old version i think he's scared of
you yeah that's what he scared me yeah
oh me because he loves the lyrics yeah
he likes the litter i was trying to make
excuses it's cool because in the
beginning they did have a little
introduction of how to acclimate your
cats to this so we actually need to put
some kitty litter in here which i assume
you have i forgot to bring you some no i
have some okay let me get my phone and
connect it to the app
[Music]
what should we name it
how about
ed's potty
i'm connecting a kitty litter robot gear
robot is connected and will be ready so
a clean cycle is going to begin shortly
okay i think we need to
probably put some kitty litter in here
this is great because ed has one of the
older versions so he's basically a
professional at this we're just
upgrading his crib well the cat's crib
should we load it up
okay
do you think that you can get them
to pee or poo on command
can you hear me
no
i mean we could certainly try should we
take a bet on who's going to do it first
oh probably oh
wow
you guys have to meet link and gus they
are
so freaking cute like they're the
coolest cats i've ever met if we just
back up and let them
like okay natural instincts take over
okay let's see okay so we're just gonna
go about our business
you got a customer we have a customer oh
my god where's buster
this is the best day of my life
oh my
god oh my god
or do we have a potty do you think he's
gonna do oh yeah i'm gonna stop talking
good boy wink no way
i feel so
uncomfortable zero privacy
do you think he's making a turd maybe
does it oh my gosh there is a oh there's
p
he's covering it up this is this is like
some sort of like nature show yeah how
do they know how to do that link how did
you get litter
oh
good job we're so proud of you
that was a very good job we're so proud
of you
so ed we had our first customer yeah i
saw that's pretty exciting it's so
exciting so it even takes the pet weight
9.24 pounds that's awesome cat detected
inside globe at 348 it's even showing
how full the drawer level is 33 full now
when you when they pee like you just
kind of let it go right yeah it just
dries up and uh when that starts to run
after a few minutes when it knows the
cat's not in there it waits a few
minutes it lets it kind of get a little
soaked up and when it rotates a pea will
become just as much of like a you know
thing as a as a little turd and it just
gets filtered right out from the screen
do you think that we can get a turd
today
so i feel like i met lincoln gus like
when they were babies yeah after moving
out here
i would call my parents or facetime them
just to see my cat i you know was really
lonely i wanted to
have cats again i'm a cat person it just
so happened after about nine months of
searching i lucked out and found lincoln
gus they were born within the same week
two separate litters two separate types
of cats but they knew each other and
that meant a lot to me and 11 years
later i think it means a lot to that so
they're so sweet they're my favorite i
mean i just like this is easy to clean
too like here you go all of your waste
is here you have the litter liner you
can just throw that away yeah this just
pops off too so you can clean that
i just can't believe that we got
a p on demand yeah link you're a great
patient thank you so much for your for
your service
i was just really excited when they
reached out and told me that they had
this coming out because i'm a huge fan
of like pet products like there's so
many cool things out there and the fact
that this one has been around for a
while and they have this it's all new
all upgraded and the fact that you can
monitor this from an app is so
incredible we have the time we have the
weight of your cat that went in which is
good because people way
who did a number one or a number two
based on their weight because gus weighs
like two pounds or about a pound and a
half more than link and that helps me to
understand that the cats are going to
the bathroom and if they're not they
might be stressed or there might be a
problem and now that it has the weight i
can tell which one has gone well thank
you guys so much for watching and ed
thank you so much for participating in
our little review video here thank you
this is so exciting if you guys want to
get more information about the little
robot 4 by whisker i'll put a link in
the description and with that i'll see
you guys later you got to keep us
updated when you when you get a number
two oh yeah i'll catch you every time
okay great yeah just send me some
screenshots of of the app
i'll send you the weight too all right
bye guys thank you
ed just so happens to have some fake poo
so for the sake of the demo we're gonna
test it out
it's also cool because you can manually
do a cycle with these buttons there it
goes i didn't even think that we were
going to be able to test the turret and
here here we are
there it is
oh my gosh it's going away there it goes
i don't know why i'm so amused but this
is incredible yeah it's pretty great
[Music]